this video is sponsored by facto which
means we'll have an ad from them
somewhere in the middle
hello everyone and welcome to another
episode of good gaming news which is a
weekly ish has been like a month because
I went home spent time with my family it
was actually the longest I think I have
gone without making any kind of content
in over 10 years which is wild but it's
a mostly weekly show where I talk about
all of the good news to come out of
video games because there are certainly
enough people on YouTube covering the
bad news and I get that it gets more
views but I don't care about views I
care about video games so we are
starting with the announcement of a
developer Direct on January 25th at 12
pm PT or 3 pm ET 8pm GMT I was going to
say 6mt but that doesn't make sense this
is an announcement from post on
news.xbox.com and I definitely consider
it good news uh because it feels like
it's been a little bit quiet from Xbox
recently obviously they announced
everything that they had coming out
quite early in the year last year didn't
show anything at the game awards and I
mentioned this on a stream recently but
I did see some people say that they felt
like I think it was an IGN headline
actually they felt like Xbox not having
a presence at the game awards was a slap
in the face to Xbox Gamers and I didn't
really understand that and then I feel
like Microsoft was very very clear clear
about when they had their conferences
earlier in the year that was what they
had for the next 12 months and so they
laid all their cards out and let
everybody know early this is what's
coming out in the next 12 months you
have it I wasn't expecting to see
anything from Xbox at the game awards so
it didn't feel like a loss to me but
then I guess remitting on a little bit
more now there are certainly games that
are now closer to coming out
um that we probably do need to know a
little bit more about I would love to
see a little bit more about the hollow
Knight silk song though worth noting
that is not one of the games that has
been confirmed to be in this conference
so the News Post says Xbox and Bethesda
will present a developer Direct on
Wednesday January 25th providing fans
with an inside look at some of the games
coming to Xbox PC and Game Pass over the
next few months presented by the game
creators themselves from Studios
including Arcane Austin at Mojang
Studios turn 10 Studios and xenomax
online Studios the developer direct will
focus on big features extended gameplay
showcases which you always love to see
and the latest info for Xbox games
launching in the next few months
including the Elder Scrolls Online Forza
Motorsport Minecraft Legends and and
redfull I imagine for most people
redfull is going to be the most
interesting one here
I changed my webcam setup because this
aspect ratio of this article is a little
strange yeah it's not that we haven't
seen redfold but I feel like we're
probably due for a couple more updates
for anyone who's not already sold on
that game well obviously every other one
of these is something that already
exists and I love that they called this
out to dedicate the proper amount of
time for a deep dive into Bethesda game
studios Starfield a standalone show is
in the works which is such a good idea
get it out of the way tell people
they're not going to see Star field here
which has got to be one of the most
anticipated games of this year probably
very closely behind Zelda just tell
everybody hey you're not going to see it
here you are going to see big dives into
these games I feel like people always
get carried away with video game
conferences like not having what they
wanted to see and sometimes gonna be
honest
think it's because you're not paying
enough attention they're usually pretty
candid about what's going to be in them
you just have to like read a blog post
or don't just watch this video I got you
reading who needs it it is time to talk
about facto which is a prepared meal
delivery service that I personally have
been using for the last three months
straight and I absolutely love it Factor
fully cuts out meal planning and
extensive prepping so meals can come
together in minutes it takes the
guesswork out of what to make for
breakfast lunch or dinner so you start
by choosing your preferences which will
give you the most relevant meals but you
can still swap between them when you
place your orders every week there is
Chef's Choice plus keto calorie smart
vegan and veggie and Protein Plus you
can also choose how many meals you want
per week and from there you get to pick
from a flexible menu every single week
the reason I love factors so much is
actually that sometimes I just run out
of time I run out of time to make myself
a meal and I end up ordering something
that looks tasty on some delivery app
that's usually fast food and is
massively overpriced and it comes Cold
anyway with facta I never let myself get
into that pickle I'm ordering the food
ahead of time choosing dishes that I
really love I actually really love the
pork tenderloin basically it is great
for my lifestyle the meals arrived
pre-prepared and ready to eat in two
minutes or less which is obviously
faster than ordering in and there's a
rotating weekly menu of 27 plus meal
options and 33 plus add-ons like
smoothies keto shakes desserts and more
I ordered that one this week very
excited obviously it's very helpful for
helping you meet your fitness goals plus
hey pretty good for gamers too fact is
no hassle prepared foods make sure you
always have something nutritious on hand
when you don't have time to think about
making lunch or dinner grab a prepared
smoothie or keto shake for a quick snack
or heat and eat a chef quality meal in
just two minutes with no prep or cleanup
necessary so you can focus on what you
love to do so use my link or go to
go.factor75.com and use code POG Alana
gen 60 for 60 off your first box so for
The Elder Scrolls Online we'll have the
studio director unveiling 2023's major
chapter update including the latest
regions of Tamriel to become playable in
ESO as well as a major new feature
update coming in the game's biggest
update of this year Forza Motorsport
we'll have the team at turn 10 Studios
showing off the next generation of Forza
Motorsport built from the ground up to
take advantage of the Xbox series X
slash S I still don't really know how
you're supposed to say that X and s x
what is that I want to know what that
thing is called did you know it's called
a vertical bar
I didn't that is a vertical bar okay
from now on I'm calling it Xbox series X
vertical bias for Minecraft Legends
which I actually enjoyed way more than I
expected to Mojang or Mo Yang as I
believe it's actually called well
showcase an Insider's look into the PVP
multiplayer experience in Minecraft
Legends the upcoming action strategy
game from the makers of Minecraft wait
upcoming
if I only played like an open beta
version and not realized that oops
developed in partnership with Blackbird
interactive and launching this spring
don't miss exclusive gameplay footage at
the developer direct and finally redfold
the minds behind Dishonored and prey
Arcane Austin will showcase several
minutes of gameplay from their upcoming
FPS the developer direct will reveal
single and multiplayer gameplay showing
you more of how you and your friends
will take down bloodthirsty vampires on
the picturesque island of redfall
Massachusetts fans can expect to learn
more about combat customization bosses
the open world and more I am looking
forward to it and yes I will stream this
conference for all of you
I'll do it here on YouTube because I'm
starting to do conferences here on
YouTube and I do like other streams on
Twitch obviously
so join me Wednesday January 25th at 12
pm PT I'll take my lunch break to watch
this looking forward to it nothing huge
in here nothing mind-wowingly exciting
but nice to get some updates on some
games people like next up just something
really worth celebrating and that is
that the Dead Space remake which I am so
excited about especially since finishing
Callisto protocol and not feeling like
it filled the dead space hole in my
heart unfortunately I think I'll make a
video about how I felt about cluster
protocol next week I understand that
would be very late after launch but I
have thoughts but the Dead Space remake
comes with Dead Space 2 as a free steam
game which is just awesome not a lot of
me to the story just something cool it
is worth noting though that
um it doesn't look like the pre-purchase
offer appears on the epic game store
there seems to be exclusive to steam but
it does also require a pre-order which I
generally you know tend to recommend but
still cool Dead Space 2 is very good I
think Dead Space 2 holds up I even think
Dead Space holds up to be honest despite
being excited about the Remake so this
is great news next up is something that
I am extremely excited about though do
have to give the disclosure I work at
PlayStation technically and I have
worked on accessibility at PlayStation
so bias ethics whatever
um still very very excited about this I
I just so stoked that this is finally
happening and do think it's a little bit
overdue um this is on the Playstation
blog and says introducing project
Leonardo for PlayStation 5 a highly
customizable accessibility controller
kit this is what it looks like a lot of
you probably already seen the Xbox
adaptive controller this is the
PlayStation version of that and for any
console Warriors who would have any
comment on this I did see some of it on
Twitter and just think it's so nuts
people like all copying Xbox Xbox do it
first
accessibility is about accessibility you
want all platforms to have this kind of
thing so that disabled Gamers have
access to being able to play games on
all platforms making it a console well I
think doesn't make any sense to me I
don't know why I even I even
regurgitated your dumb talking points so
it is designed to remove barriers to
gaming and help players with
disabilities play more easily more
comfortably and for longer periods on
PS5 of course accessibility is an
important topic to us at PlayStation and
we want to continue raising the bar to
enable every gamer to experience the joy
of play whether it's the robust
accessibility options in PlayStation
Studios games like Santa Monica Studios
God or Ragnarok they worked on this or
Naughty Dogs the last was part one or
the wide array of features in our PS4
and PS5 console UI the passionate about
reducing barriers to play for every
gamer today at CES we announce the next
step in our journey to make gaming more
accessible project Leonardo for
PlayStation 5. developed with key
contributors from accessibility experts
community members and game developers
project Leonardo is our code name for
our highly for a new sorry highly
customizable controller kit that works
out of the box to help many players with
disabilities play games more easily more
comfortably and for longer periods and I
know they did well it says here it's
gonna say did consult able gave me
special effect and Stack Up um yeah it's
it's really cool and it does work with
It also says that right here third party
accessibility accessories I keep going
to say things that of course the
Playstation blog is going to cover
and yeah it helps players with limited
motor control including difficulty
holding and controlling for long periods
accurately pressing small Clauses of
buttons or triggers or positioning
thumbs and fingers optimally on a
standard controller it has different
analog sticks different button sizes
different caps for all different range
of motion or um physical needs obviously
supports button remapping which is a
huge one because not a lot of games
offer that functionality so the
controller doing it for you is just a
huge win and I like this a lot the
controller profiles means players can
store their program button settings as
control profiles and easily switch
between them by pressing the profile
button so yeah very very cool excited to
see it happening trust great news across
the board next up because I think this
kind of thing is really neat Avatar
frontiers of Pandora I worked with James
Cameron's production company to push the
tech envelope like the movies now I have
not seen Avatar wave water they're just
not that interested in it but I think
it's currently if I recall the seventh
highest grossing movie of all time so
it's clearly doing well I know my dad
went to see it and if you get my dad to
see a movie in the cinemas it's popping
off but
um watching the trailer the water
effects do look incredible and one thing
that I really respect about James
Cameron and like undeniably valuable
regarding his contribution to film in
general is that he pushes the envelope
pushes the tech Envelope as Games Radar
would phrase it for all the money he
spent making something like Avatar way
of water video games can also be helped
and supposedly Avatar front is a Pandora
which is the Ubisoft game that has been
in production for over five years now is
one of those Tech envelope push
situations
to put it delicately
the article says Avatar frontiers of
Pandora is looking to push the
technological envelope forwards just
like games games Cameron just like James
Cameron's movies The Game's creative
director said the time has been spent on
building a brand new part of Pandora and
creating the tools needed to bring it to
life on the latest generation of console
and PC Hardware at the heart of this
epic is Snowdrop our game engine when we
first met with light storm the James
cameron-led production company Snowdrop
is what showed to our partners that we
were willing to push the envelope of
Technology just like they do in the
films it was and still is the key
Foundation of our ongoing collaboration
which is awesome is is this a real raid
Shadow Legends ad is are you trying is
Rage Shadow Legend sexy it's not what I
thought of it but hey now maybe no we'll
play it Ubisoft massive the studio in
charge of the avatar game has been long
working on the technology for the new
game with the project being in
production for at least five years
Ubisoft massive has been continually
learning from and collaborating with
light storm entertainment and Disney of
course obviously you don't want to ruin
one of your like biggest money making
IPS at this point but not a lot of
detail here unfortunately I'm just
generally glad to hear it and would love
to hear more it's a cool collaboration
between the two industries which is
slowly happening more and more like we
know um the TV industry is starting to
use unreal which I guess includes film
too
um in part because of the the volume the
thing that they use for Star Wars that
actually runs on unreal there is a lot
of room for collaboration between the
two industries in terms of of uh Tech
things like lighting are huge with way
of order way of the water and imagine
they're going to want to tap into making
sure that Avatar frontiers of Pandora is
just as pretty as the Avatar movies
because that's such a selling point I
feel like that's got to be very
important to Ubisoft and very important
to Disney especially which probably
means some cool advancements they can't
just kind of sit on their Laurels with
this one you've got a Disney IP that is
almost sold on how stunning it is
graphically the game's gonna have to
live up to that and I'm just stoked to
hear it and last but not least here
video game sales evade strong economic
headwinds for the time being basically
there have been some economic
occurrences of late economic pressures
as they call it a triple whammy of
economic pressures as they call it in
the UK uh does definitely sound like
things are getting spicy over there but
um video games have not been affected
and I know that people before have said
that they think video games are immune
to recessions and I I do not have the
knowledge to dispute that but there are
some interesting statistics in here so
inflation in the UK arose by 11 the 12
months to November 2022 and UK Texas is
some of the highest on record The
Five-Year average tax burden is at a
70-year high right now wow that leads
consumers to feel unconfident which is
worse than it was at the beginning of
the pandemic allegedly and one area that
a household budget could be construed as
an easy decision to cut back on is the
amount spent on entertainment when it
comes to food house payments and energy
discretionary spending on entertainment
by contrast is often way down on the
list of priorities therefore you would
think of video games full alas they have
not spending on video game titles is
actually currently breaking records
recent headlines have included Pokemon
scarlet and violet becoming the fastest
selling game in Nintendo history
Splatoon 3 sales surpassing 3 million
units in Japan after its first two
months God of War Ragnarok having the
biggest launch in its franchise history
and ecology Modern Warfare 2 launch
sales doubling that of Vanguard the
trend in sales growth here is also not
just confined to the fourth quarter of
2022 which is something we do often see
it was new releases really across the
board the top 10 new box games generated
31 more sales in 2022 than their 2021
counterpart accepting FIFA for boxed if
I'm reading this correctly like the
growth in retail disk sales unit sales
for full game digital downloads
increased by 52 2022 compared to 2021.
when you combine new game releases for
box sales and digital full game
downloads there are an additional 1.5
million units sold in 2022 compared to
2021 so just generally good news for the
industry across the board video games
are currently quite healthy people like
them turns out
that is all for me today everybody I
will see you all next week happy gaming
bye